I I do want to just briefly talk
about uh when you were on the show that
I was on where I played the bald guy uh
I just want to know it is interesting
seeing you with hair yeah and by the way
I'm getting a haircut today it's all
over the freaking Place good thanks but
um who would have thought you had so
much of it huh I know right yeah I I was
hoping that my hair would eventually
grow I wouldn't that be sort of like you
you shave your head for seven years and
then you're bald and your hair and I
used to worry Greg Beaman who was a
producer and director on on the show I
love Greg I love Greg he said to me yeah
because he directed you he said to me
hey just think Rosen bomb everybody else
on this show will look the same when
they leave but not you you'll have hair
and I
go God
damn I always thought that then it gave
me a little bit like okay that's good
but say yeah but what was your time what
was it like on there were you nervous at
all coming on because this was like one
of your first big things right oh my God
it was the first thing I ever did that
actually aired i' done like a pilot at
that point oh this might have been my
second paying job I mean there was one
and it was not a porn but it's
definitely not on my IMDb because it's
that you know horror movie that you
always just you're like I got paid to do
that but I never need to see it and
other people don't either so kind of
like the third paying job and not only
that
on said whatever we were on um the first
day on set I had to be in a pasty
pasties and a thong oh my boy walk
through the woods in Vancouver and I
want to say it was like October or
November it was freaking cold but I was
also like hey crew here's me
naked including you know Tom who had to
open the door and like literally was
looking anywhere but at me he was so
uncomfortable yeah and by the way every
crew member to this day says it was the
best day in the history of their film
making
oh seeing you in the woods with pasties
but you know what I remember this I
remember just hearing how cool you were
and what a sport you were and how fun
funny you were that's what I remember I
don't remember like oh man she's hot or
this I remember everybody just really
liking you oh that's cool well it's true
it's true you're a fun person and you're
a team player and uh so yes the first
time you meet Tom I guess you're you're
supposed to play this naked girl who's
supposedly from
Krypton correct correct and were you
nervous of
course of course Tom's
hatot Tom's hat I heard the Toledo
accent I heard heard your Toledo accent
Tom's hat oh my God he's from freaking
Toledo
um he is hot you know U but you were hot
you're still hot you know I met you at
the slutting Place yep when I was
shooting the first thing I ever did
which was a pilot which was before then
so I actually you made me feel so
comfortable because going on to it I
already knew you see we met at we met at
the hot tubs the hot tubs yeah I was
running like cuz I I used to go to the
hot tub late at night where there was
nobody there it was completely empty and
I'd sit in the hot tub and I just
learned my lines by myself and nobody
would be there and occasionally if there
was somebody there I would just stop
obviously learning lines and just sit
there and if they stay too long I'd
leave but I remember I think I was
learning lines and then you you came
into the hot tub yep but I I think at
one point I helped you learn your life
yeah I think you did yeah I think you
actually initiated and said hey you want
to read you want to read that like you
were cool about it as I recall but um
it's good memory
what when you watched the episode were
you were you really excited because it
was one of the best episodes ever oh uh
yeah well I've only seen it once and it
was when it
aired and my
manager my managers put together kind of
a little screening party h
which I don't know about you I I don't
love watching myself especially in front
of other people definitely not for the
first time yeah I have to know if it's
good or not right yeah it's like cringy
I get really uncomfortable oh man it's
it's the worst when you haven't seen
something and you're watching you're
just mic judging it the entire time hey
guys I'm doing another live podcast
downtown LA at the Regent Theater and my
special guest for January 24th is
Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad Jessica
Jones this is going to be a soldout
event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited